[MUSIC PLAYING]
QUENTIN HARDY: I'd
like to welcome
our special guests,
Renee Murphy,
Principal Analyst for Security
and Risk at Forrester,
and Ben McCormack, Vice
President of Operations
at Evernote.
Renee, can you tell
us a little bit
about your work at Forrester
on security in the enterprise
and how Cloud figures into that?
RENEE MURPHY: Yeah,
so I work at Forrester
as a principal analyst
in governance, risk,
and compliance.
So I work with chief
information security officers
on the risk question
about the cloud.
And from a security
perspective, I'll
say that that's usually the
very first question they have.
How secure is the cloud?
Are they going to be
responsible for my problems?
The first thing
you can try to do
is tell them, listen, take
any Cloud best practice,
go into your own data center,
and see if you'll pass that.
And they'll come
back and tell me,
there's no way we can do this.
I'm like, right.
Well then--
QUENTIN HARDY: Not much
left to talk about.
RENEE MURPHY: Right?
It's like, someone
else can it better.
You might want to do it.
So I think that's how they
first come to the question.
Like Like, what am
I really giving up?
And I say, you're not
giving up anything
except the spinning
disk in your space.
That's all you're giving up.
You're actually
enhancing your security.
You're enhancing
your availability.
What makes Cloud
more effective is
you can hire people
I can't hire.
You can have huge data
centers that I can't have.
QUENTIN HARDY: Me
being all of Google.
RENEE MURPHY: All of Google.
QUENTIN HARDY: OK.
RENEE MURPHY: You can do that.
Right?
You can do it in a way I can't.
And listen, the more of
us that go to the cloud,
the better you're
going to get at it.
And the better you
get at it, the better
I'm going to be at it.
And I think at the
end of the day,
if you're in the business
of doing anything
other than managing
data centers,
then why are you
managing the data center?
QUENTIN HARDY: Ben,
let me bring you in.
Last year, you did migrate
your data centers over
to Google Cloud.
Tell us a little bit
about that experience.
Does the security
side of that mirror
what Rene is talking about?
Or did you have other
interests and concerns?
BEN MCCORMACK: I'd
say broadly, yes.
For us, it was about
allowing our teams
to focus on what was important
to our end customers.
We've got hundreds
of millions of users
who we are helping collect
information, retrieve
information, and help
them be more efficient.
Being an expert in running
a physical data center
doesn't directly support that.
So for us, it was about
allowing our technical teams--
and you're right.
You move to Cloud, you do not
get rid of your technical team.
RENEE MURPHY: Nope.
BEN MCCORMACK: Or
if you do, you're
going to realize it's a
mistake really quickly.
There are things you are
doing in the physical data
center that will be
replaced in the cloud.
You need to become an expert
at the cloud provider's control
plane, et cetera, et cetera.
But for us, it
was about focusing
our company and
our staff on things
that were important
to our users and also
allowing our development
teams and software
engineers to move a lot faster.
So for us, the rate
of change and the rate
of innovation in the
cloud space is way faster
than we can ever achieve.
QUENTIN HARDY: That's
the proposition in Cloud,
that it automates a lot
of the [INAUDIBLE] work.
You don't pull cable anymore.
You don't destroy
hard drive anymore.
You outsource all that
to another provider
in a large centralized area.
And developers can move faster.
If they have better
tools, they can scale.
Ultimately, security questions
are about having your business
relationships threatened.
And you must have had
security questions going in.
What were they like?
And how were they
best addressed?
BEN MCCORMACK: So for us,
I think it was twofold.
We initially started with
our standard security
questionnaires.
We went through those.
And then what our
security team actually did
was paused a couple of months
in and actually started
risk-modeling or threat-modeling
what were the risks that we
were looking at in Cloud.
The risk model is not,
is the cloud provider
going to lose a hard drive?
The risk model is what happens
if you lose your, effectively,
your root password in
your Cloud account.
So we went through our
standard process first.
We learned from that
in the first cycle.
And then we updated
our threat modeling.
And then reasked the questions
to Google and reengaged.
And I think the
other thing, we just
went through a
period of learning
that you have to--
to go to Cloud means
you've got to trust somebody.
QUENTIN HARDY: Is there
some kind of corollary
where security is concerned?
Are the security teams
working in different ways
on more valuable stuff?
BEN MCCORMACK: It's
broadly exactly the same.
So the security team
and the legal teams
have still got to verify
all the certifications
with the provider.
You've got to go through
the security certifications,
the questionnaires.
None of that changes.
But what the security team is
not having to do is audit--
we use this example-- physical
hard drive destruction.
They're not having to
audit physical hard drive
destruction logs every quarter.
And for us, the question becomes
if they're not doing that,
what can they be
spending their time on?
They can spend more time on
securing the application, more
time helping our developers
write more secure code,
and more time
chasing people that
are trying to hack
our application,
not trying to hack our
physical data centers.
So for us, I think on the
security side as well,
it allows them to
move up the stack
and focus on things
that are more
important to our customers.
And ultimately, that's
what it's about.
It's about your customers.
It's not about the running
physical data centers.
That's how we saw it.
QUENTIN HARDY: And
you're offering your team
more interesting and
challenging work.
It is a new landscape.
What do you wish
you'd known beforehand
about security specifically?
BEN MCCORMACK: For us,
there hasn't really been--
there's been no big surprises
on the security side.
We did all of our due
diligence upfront.
Our security team and our
legal team spent a lot of time
with the Google
teams understanding
the nuances of Cloud, what
did it provide, what didn't it
provide.
The big surprise for us has
been how quickly our software
engineers embraced the cloud.
And in some ways, we're
having to play catch-up.
QUENTIN HARDY: It's
interesting you say this,
because you're telling me that
the IT teams stay in place.
Security stays in place.
They're involved
in different work,
so there's some change
management involved.
And you see a competitive
differentiator
for the enterprise
in going to Cloud.
What was that about?
BEN MCCORMACK: I think you
gotta look at the macro picture.
We're losing the battle.
Breaches are getting
larger and larger.
Threat actors are getting
more and more sophisticated.
And as an industry, I'm
not sure we're actually
winning that battle.
But if you can focus less on
some of the security layers
and allow your
cloud provider, who
has scale, who can apply
automation, who can apply,
we hope in the future,
machine learning
to some of those things, it
frees up security professionals
to focus on our
applications' security.
And I think it's one
of the ways that we
may start stemming
the tide of losing
the battle against hacks.
QUENTIN HARDY: And Renee,
you speak to many businesses.
How does security figure
in for most of them
as becoming some sort of
competitive differentiator?
RENEE MURPHY: What
we're trying to manage--
businesses, when
they talk to me,
they're trying to manage
reputational risk.
Right?
And so what do you end
up with after a breach?
You have damaged reputation.
Right?
And so everybody's
trying to control that.
And actually, it's how they
get funding these days.
We don't talk about threaten
and vulnerabilities anymore.
We talk about the impact to
the business's reputation.
Are we going to be labeled
another company who can't seem
to keep their data together?
QUENTIN HARDY: Will
there be a massive fine?
RENEE MURPHY: And will
Yeah, that's not
even funny anymore.
So we can't ignore it.
So I think from a
differentiator perspective
that if you are spending
your time, like Ben said,
working on other things,
securing your application,
making better code, having
security deployed somewhere
else so that they
can be meaningful,
I think that's all part
of being a differentiator,
a competitive differentiator.
QUENTIN HARDY: And of
course, the customers
are also thinking, how is
this going to change my life?
And so for a security
engineer, when
you talk about cloud security
and how pervasive or full stack
or depth of hardware,
software, security integration,
whatever, what are they
thinking about what
they're going to do next if that
part of their job goes away?
RENEE MURPHY: Yeah.
See, that's it.
We spend a lot of
time telling them,
we need to figure out
a way to get you out
of the day-to-day
stuff of security,
looking at patching,
looking at incidences,
trying to figure out if the
threat and vulnerability
management system is
giving us false positives.
So for me, it's all about
managing that third party,
having a partnership,
understanding
who's responsible for what,
negotiating that ahead of time.
Right?
In a breach, who
notifies who of what?
In a security incident, how are
we going to communicate that?
Because you may be
communicating to me.
But I need to communicate
to an entire organization.
So we need to be
in sync with that.
We need to negotiate
change management.
incident management.
If I'm in a heavily
regulated industry
and you're making infrastructure
changes, I have to know.
QUENTIN HARDY: So
transparency is available.
Exploit it.
Use it as much.
RENEE MURPHY: Yes,
absolutely do it.
And if you're in a heavily
regulated industry,
have one conversation
with the regulators
before you go down this road to
understand their expectations.
And if you have internal
audit, have them involved.
BEN MCCORMACK: The
landscape has changed.
And I think the next generation
of IT professionals, security
professionals, need
to be cloud-ready.
They need to be less thinking
about how do I secure a router
and more thinking about how
do I secure my Cloud account,
how do I secure my keys, and
continue on that journey.
So I think it's a journey
up the stack for all of us.
When I started in
the industry, we
used to argue about
what physical network
card to put in a server.
RENEE MURPHY: [LAUGHS] Yeah.
BEN MCCORMACK: We did.
It was an argument.
It took you a month of time to
discuss what version of card
you would put in.
We're constantly
moving up the stack.
And it's only going to continue.
And it's going to move
faster and faster.
QUENTIN HARDY: And
Ben, what do you
see your security teams working
on a year or two from now?
BEN MCCORMACK: So what
we're trying to assess
is how far can we
go down the route
of serverless architectures, not
worrying about infrastructure,
continuing to obstruct
further and further away
from the underlying
infrastructure.
We're not sure it's
quite there yet.
But we know it's coming
very, very quickly.
And we want to be
ready to embrace that.
QUENTIN HARDY: A more integrated
and automated stack, basically.
BEN MCCORMACK: Basically, yeah.
Embracing things
like Cloud Functions,
and embracing those
higher value services.
Renee said it.
Why worry about
securing the container?
Worry about securing the code.
Worry about writing secure code.
So for us, it's a
continual abstraction.
It's never going to stop.
And it's only going
to get faster.
QUENTIN HARDY: What does the
future hold for security?
What do you see happening next?
What do you think businesses
should be thinking about?
RENEE MURPHY: Well,
I think businesses
should be thinking about getting
comfortable with the idea
that you don't need to
manage this yourself.
I think we should
see this as fully
outsourced from a
security perspective,
between the managed
security service
providers or cloud providers.
I think we, we as
organizations, should get out
of that business.
We shouldn't be in the
business of securing data.
We should have companies that
are very good at securing data.
We should share
that risk with them.
We should do that because
you hired all the best
people that I can't afford.
Right?
You hired all the best
people that I can't afford.
BEN MCCORMACK:
She's got a point.
RENEE MURPHY: So I may as well
have you manage that for me.
Listen, if I'm in the
business of doing research,
should I be in the business
of running a data center?
Again, no.
No, I shouldn't be.
Right?
Other people are better at it.
QUENTIN HARDY: Talk
to the provider.
Get a roadmap for what's
going to get automated next,
and think about the
value-added security layer
you might put on top of that.
That's great advice.
[MUSIC PLAYING]